-♪♪ Virtual Reality Pictionary ♪♪
-First, we're
going to need partners,
and we found some good ones.
Joining my team is the star
of "Pacific Rim Uprising."
Please welcome John Boyega!
♪♪♪♪
How are you feeling?
You feeling it?
-[ Growls ]
-[ Laughs ]
Tariq's partner tonight --
Her new movie, "Midnight Sun,"
is in theaters on Friday.
Give it up for Bella Thorne!
Hey!
Bella! Hi, Bella!
I need to say hi
before the competition.
All right. We're gonna
be cordial about it.
-Before the competition.
Here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
Now, the game works
exactly like Pictionary.
That's my -- That's my game --
Except the person who is drawing
will be wearing one of these
virtual-reality headsets
and drawing in 3-D space
using a program
called Tilt Brush, okay?
We'll be able to see
their point of view
on the big screen upstage.
45 seconds per turn.
I will go first.
You guys can all
take your seats.
We're gonna do this, John.
-Okay.
-Here we go. All right.
Let me put this down here.
Throw this guy on.
What number?
[ Crowd shouting ]
FIVE!! Okay.
That guy aggressively
yelled five, so I'm afraid --
-Yeah, five is --
-Hmm. Okay.
Hmm. All right.
Okay. Ready?
-Jimmy, Jimmy, I'm very worried
about this, man. You're not...
-No, no, I'm playing this.
I'm playing this. Ready?
-All right, all right.
-All right. This is an object.
You ready?
-Man, you're drawing
sheepskin, man.
It just doesn't look right.
[ Laughter ]
Um, a dog?
An elephant?
-When you know what this is,
you're gonna really feel stupid.
No. I don't know.
Maybe um, um, um...
[ Laughter ]
Sorry. Sorry. Oh, no!
I'm sorry!
Don't look at that!
[ Laughs ] All right.
Wait. Oh, man.
Oh, man! Ohh!
-Time. Time!
[ Buzzer ]
-Sorry. I apologize.
I apologize to America.
That was, uh...
[ Laughter ]
I love that you
didn't even guess.
That was buffalo wings.
-Oh, wow.
[ Foghorn ]
Wow.
-I drew a buffalo
with wings on it.
-Yeah, yeah, no.
-Oh, you tried to --
-Is it my turn?
-No, not yet, Tariq.
-Okay. Okay.
-Thank you.
Bella, it's your --
Bella, you're up next.
-Oh. Goodness.
-Yeah, here you go. This is fun.
Yeah, you're gonna love this.
And you got to pick a number.
I can help you.
What number should she pick?
-Three, three, three.
They're yelling "three."
-All right.
They're saying three. All right.
-Okay. John calls it three.
Okay.
-Don't overthink it.
Don't overthink it.
-Yeah, yeah.
No, overthink it.
-Get out of here. Sit down.
-Okay.
-Okay. You got it, Bella?
Do you got the...?
-Ohh. Ohh.
-There's the controller.
-Yes. Do I draw this way?
-You can walk all around.
-Yes. Yes.
-Oh, what if I trip over
this thing in my heels?
I'm not used to wearing
so many heels.
Oh, goodness.
-You're only wearing two heels.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Good point.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay. Here we go.
Oh, what's the subject?
-It's a phrase.
-Okay.
-And it's also...an insect?
-Buggin'.
-Ooh. I don't know.
-No, you've drawn enough.
That's perfect.
Ooh, wait!
-Butterflies in your stomach?
-Uh, it's close, but, no.
It has a...
-It's 3-D. You can move around.
You can walk.
Wait.
Does that help?
[ Laughter ]
-Um, it's, um, when you're --
-Wait, wait! [ Laughs ]
It's not charades!
-When you're -- Oh.
It's not charades.
It's virtual -- it's Pictionary!
-Oh. So I can't describe it?
Bella! Keep drawing.
No, you can't --
You've got to stop talking!
-Okay, okay, God.
Let me -- I'll try again.
I'm under so much pressure!
I just keep drawing circles!
[ Buzzer ]
-Dang!
-[ Laughs ] It's fun, right?
What was it?
-You let Jimmy
get inside your head.
-What was it?
-It was a queen bee.
So I tried to draw
the little --
And I was like --
The higher up, the majesty.
No. I'm sorry.
-John, you're up.
John, you're up.
Yeah, you're up.
-All right. Cool.
-That was pretty good.
I like that.
You had the crown on it.
I saw that, yeah.
--Okay. Cool. What number
should I go for, guys?
[ Audience shouting ]
-I tried to get in
your head. Sorry.
-Oh, for freak's sake!
-Oh, come on!
John! That's not the attitude!
-All right. It is an action.
-Okay, an action.
-That has to do
with a body part.
All right.
Okay. Okay.
-Yes.
-Oh, no.
John! John!
Don't you dare draw that!
Man boobs.
-And then this section...
-Yes, the chest area.
No, the belly area.
-Belly...
-Belly fat.
Wait. It's an action.
Belly bump.
Belly, belly...
-Come on, bruh.
-Belly rub.
Belly...belly dance!
Belly dance!
-No, no, no!
-No. Belly -- Wow.
It -- It -- It -- It --
It -- It -- It --
Oh, for freak's sake!
It moves -- BLBLBLBLBLB!
-Ohh! Belly wave.
Belly...belly...
Belly trip.
-Oh, for f--
-Belly ring.
-No, no.
-Belly --
When do you do the wave?
[ Buzzer ]
Sorry. John! John!
Hey. I'm sorry, dude.
I let you down.
-Sorry.
I'm very competitive, guys.
-I'm sorry. What happened?
What was it?
-Belly flop!
-Ohh. Belly flop.
What -- This is not belly flop.
-Yeah, it flops, though, innit?
-That's not a belly flop.
-Okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-When you belly flop,
you don't do like that.
-Yeah, but a big belly --
Just freakin'...
-What are you doing?
Why you standing up?
-I'm helping you out, man.
-You trying to rig
the equipment?
-I'm helping you out, dude.
-Okay, okay.
Which one should I --
[ Audience shouting]
Okay. This is an object.
-Oh, he's so confident.
-Okay.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
Are you ready?
-You said it's an object?
-Yeah.
-Holy mackerel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God! Yo!
-Is that --
-It's a pig, but...
Pig...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-I'm so conf--
Wait. It's an object?
-Yeah.
-Oh, I know what it is.
-I know what it is, as well.
-I guess it's like a food.
-Oh. Pig in a blanket!
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is --
-You were confident,
for a good reason.
-This is insane.
-You're very good.
-Sorry.
-It's rigged! It's rigged!
-This is rigged. Wow!
That was fantastic.
Dude, you're a great artist.
Oh, my gosh.
I thought buffalo wings
was good.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, it's time
for the final round.
It's gonna be a showdown.
I will draw, and if John guesses
the clue first, then we win.
But if Tariq or Bella get it,
then they win.
-Okay?
-Okay.
-All right. Here we go.
So, what number, you guys?
[ Audience shouting ]
Here we go.
[ Laughs ] Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Oh, man, oh, man, oh, man.
All right. All right. Guys?
This is --
-Come on.
-Are we ready for this?
-Yeah, I am.
-This is an action. Okay?
Okay. Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Shout.
-Screaming.
-Screaming. Arguing.
-Yelling.
Screaming your head off.
-Spitting, spitting!
-Vomiting! Throwing up!
-Licking. Licking.
-Kissing. Making out.
-Making out.
-Kissing. Kissing with tongues.
French kiss.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Judges, who said it first?
Tell me we said it! We said it!
-We said tongue kiss.
-We got it! John Boyega!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to John Boyega,
Bella Thorne, Tariq Trotter.